[Music]
hey what's up guys it's marquez from
mkbhd and today we're taking a look at
the bose companion 2 series 2 speakers
that i believe are really great for the
price you get them for 99 bucks so if
you want to check that out that's in the
description below we're starting off
with the setup of those here and
basically how we're going to get started
here is by unboxing them of course so
thumbs up for that basically one of the
reasons people buy speakers is so that
they can have a quick easy audio
solution even if it's not difficult to
set up and for 99 bucks that is exactly
what these do they're surprisingly
simple for the price as you can see we
take them out here we can unbox them and
setting them up is as quick as just a
few steps
taking them out of the wrapping for the
first time you'll notice the series 2
are built like tanks they're made from a
magnetically shielded plastic cabinet on
the outside and we'll show that more off
later you'll also notice that one of the
speakers has all the controls on the
circuitry while the other is well a
companion so it comes with this wall
adapter that looks a little bit odd at
first but basically it comes with the
plug from the country you live in so
plug that into the wall plug your main
speaker into the wall and plug your
companion speaker into the main speaker
that's plugged into the wall and connect
your audio source to the main speaker as
well you can connect up to two audio
sources it comes with one cable but you
might want to attach a second one in the
future these speakers have great
efficiency so they'll generally run
really loud and really clear without an
amp i've listened to a lot of hours of
audio on these 99 bose speakers i've
also listened to a lot of hours of audio
on 600 iq audio studio monitors and on
29 earbuds right so that's a pretty full
range but what does 99 bucks get you out
of bows what kind of value are you going
to get out of 99 bose speakers so during
my time owning these speakers so far
i've learned a lot about why people like
them a lot about the speakers themselves
and about a lot about why they cost 99
bucks they have a pretty decent build
quality they're pretty durable the
cables are really durable and they
aren't breaking anytime soon and also
the cabinet is magnetically shielded so
you can have it right next to a monitor
with no problem i was a little bit
concerned about the cabinet size because
the only speaker itself in the companion
2 series 2 is the two and a half inch
driver up at the top so the two and a
half inch speaker is the only speaker in
each side so there's a whole lot of body
of the speaker that's not being used or
maybe it's hollow i don't really know
maybe it helps with the sound having
space in there but uh it definitely uh
confused me why it was so much bigger
than the actual speaker and i like
compact speakers so you know
i don't know so how do they actually
sound that's what people want to know
it's why they came here to see this
review we'll start from the highs and
work our way down to the lows because
that is also the order in which it falls
the highs sound great they're very very
crisp they don't overpower anything
they're not shrilly or tinny or anything
but they sound great and i definitely
like the way songs in certain genres
like certain pop songs and rock songs
guitar acoustic stuff like that jazz
sounds great the highs are excellent the
mids on the ghost 2 companion series 2
were medium i could definitely hear that
some mids were especially more prominent
in some songs so they sounded good with
again certain songs it was like hit or
miss for me with the mids and the lows
were also
decent decent at best i listened to a
lot of music like house music and and
music with a lot of bass in it already
so when i'm not hearing it in the bose 2
and i'm used to hearing it in say my m50
headphones then it's a little bit weird
to not hear that bass if you listen to a
lot of music with intentionally heavy
bass you might not like these as much or
you might want to go ahead and pick up a
subwoofer for maybe an extra 100 bucks
or 75 bucks to really fill in the sound
because the mids and highs like i said
are just fine on these speakers other
than that
yeah that's basically it those are the
bose two companion series 2. if you like
this review be sure to give it a thumbs
up it really does help me out and uh
i'll talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching
peace
[Music]
you